le temps mesdemoiselles messieurs c'est
leur honneur
les avantages l'extrême difficulté d
extirper pour vous extraire dépôt faut
maintenant qu elles qui sont cohérents
de 700 points vous ne paraissait
nullement en même temps à les extirper
quelques sont cohérents de cet
instrument
rappellez des actes mandat au trombone à
coulisse va le modèle revu et corrigé va
marcillac pas alors ce rappel pour vous
très très succinctement les principes de
fonctionnement
c'est une
et je publie comme boucher
remporter une attache dans le bosch dans
le bol
sera pas pour vous très brièvement les
principes de fonctionnement qui était
une de nombreuses réponses
abdel rahmane a ramassé la ramasse elle
c'est une des nombreuses principle
inventé par archimède savais que si m
archimède était célèbre coureur à pied
qui gagna les marathons âge aux logiques
de salamine archimède avaient l'habitude
de se décontracter en prenant des bains
et le reste c'est de pousser
cela lui donnait des idées va il
consignait sous forme de poème allemand
intitulé principes dont les plus connues
les suivants faut que tu auras sticks
and stones dj willer zone ce vigile
rigueur rôle vide m6 galère dont la
traduction est approximatif et les
suivants tout corps plongé dans l'eau
froide qui n'est pas réapparu au bout d
un graveur peut-être considérée comme
perdue
nepad et j'ai remercié mais ce n'est pas
de moi
cette semaine alors je rappelle les
principes de fonctionnement qui reste
souvent il suffit d envoyer de l'air
chaud de ce côté et de l'autre côté vous
triez voilà je vais donner tout de suite
vos échantillons des madelinots fait
accompli
on
sonorités de l'autobus madeleine
passe-t-il
je suis un peu bas je suis un peu parce
et instruments il est bon que vous
passez votre éducation musicale pas cet
instrument à cordes un tyran ou poussant
sur la becque pas alors maintenant
normalement je devrais jouer plus juste
sera en réalité j'aurais moins fort
d'après les principes de relativité de
einstein un camarade
archimaine francs en amérique un sérum
un précieux chacun à son fils arrêté au
nom de quoi
la musique cela tirait net de mater de
l'expo monet
alors comment
nous
beaucoup des tonnelles propos mais moi
je vous rend si spécial a fait ce matin
c'est sans fin sur la tradition
j'ai pu aller au diable de ta famille et
les mises à mort en france jean
sébastien faisant une fugue ensemble a
alors greta la fille du colonel s'avance
en dehors de celui dans les france
proposera
vous
ne trouvez pas le soliste ou aux 182
millions de téléspectateurs
pour fédérer tout seul à la maison
autant démunie suspends ton vol autour
de la terre a fait plus de miel on
progresse à la vie des gens mais on
comprend bien que je ne me choque pas
à chaque étape